hey guys I'm Adam rap on I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm here to play a little
game
hello and welcome to how gay is that the
game show where we ask celebrities to
tell us how gay an inanimate object is
let's do it
here's your host Adam rip on that first
saw I'm very hungry I look how to a
toast this is more of like a millennial
thing here's the thing this is what
they're not telling you this is what the
liberal media doesn't want to share with
you all Millennials are gay
every millennial is a little gay and it
all started with avocado toasts from one
to ten
avocado toast
this is kale see I have a problem with
kale because it's the most disgusting of
all the greens on a scale from 1 to 10
this is about a 5 because if it were
going it would taste better peaches
we took the peach and we repurposed its
symbolism sending a peach emoji is a
great way to ask a friend for a but pic
where does he [ __ ] the page in call me
by your name he's this oh that's nasty
on a scale from 1 to 10 a peach is about
a 9
classic oh you know what I always wish
that my clothes
closed from the back make this this is
just too easy it's too typical a doll
doesn't excite me in the way that it
should
six this is my club drink of choice so
this is BuzzFeed so I will like have
some of the best yeah this is gay it's
just straight up is like a homosexual
propaganda it's not even noon yet nine
all right very funny so we have an
eggplant
yeah yeah this is an emoji it's like so
funny
send us everybody eggplant cucumber you
got it first of all I don't like
eggplants I know what it symbolizes but
I'm just not going to go there eggplant
you better step it up three he's so cute
he's so funny so nice it has a beard
these are all the characteristics of the
common sexual baby you're gay I know it
everyone else knows it on a scale from
one to ten Gus Kenworthy
perfect ten well that was how gay is
this yeah really is Bukka Soto I just
want to say thanks so much and I'm out
of there
thanks for watching and remember
inanimate objects can't have sexualities
so this game is pointless
[Music]